hello believe nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all the major problems of the world I
started a mentor me series on this
channel with the goal to hang on people
who have done a lot more than us and
hopefully by watching more of their
content some of their thoughts their
mindset their beliefs their attitudes
their way of thinking seeps into us to
help us become the best version of
ourselves so today we're going to learn
from Maya Angelou and some of her most
inspiring moments mentor me Maya
moment number four is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys liked the best
also as Maya's talking if she says
something that really inspired you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired as well and when you write
it down yourself it's much more likely
to stick so you remember to enjoy
[Music]
you
I've tried a lot of bangle I failed it
in some things and succeeded it yeah but
what I love about you is that you have
you have attacked it all with great
passion and I can look at all the books
here that you have written I can look at
all the things you have done from
journalists to poet to writer to actor
to producer all of those kinds of things
which suggest this uncommon confidence
in yourself and willingness to risk yeah
failure yes yes but it maybe it's more
dangerous to risk to risk success we
mean well a lot of people don't really
want success I've never understood that
this is true it's intimate because they
don't want it and the best evidence of
that is they avail they say oh and
abettor best evidence of that is they
don't try that sign right that's right
but to succeed means that I mean you're
in front of God and and lots of
responsible people then you have to to
either eat your words or or stand by
them I think that I have agreed a long
time ago Charlie Rose this may be what I
might my greatest blessing I agreed long
a long time ago that I would die now if
I can admit that but no matter what
happens I will do this thing this is the
biggest Bugaboo of them all I will do
that well then why couldn't I attempt
something lesser yeah so I will try was
the 16th
once again life for anybody what was the
89 assassination what does that do to
your generation and lives with it at
having no news people this is me and I'm
man enough I still be angry I'm being
angry with my country I'll be angry at
anybody let it happen come along if
you're not angry you're either a stone
are you too sick to be angry it's just
the angry what you do even imagine
there's a difference you must not be
bitter
also that let me show you why bitterness
is like cancer it eats it on the host it
doesn't do anything to the object of its
displeasure so use that anger yes you
write it you paint it you dance it you
might it you see vote if you do
everything about it you talk it never
stop talking it when I was seven and a
half I was raped
I won't say severely they don't rate
this severe the rapist was a person very
well-known to my family I was
hospitalized the rapist was let out of
jail and was found dead that night and
the police suggested that the rapist had
been kicked to death I was seven and a
half I thought that I had caused the
man's death because I had spoken his
name
[Music]
that was my seven and a half year logic
so I stopped talking for five years now
to show you again how out of evil there
can come good in those five years I read
every book in the black school library I
read all the books I could get from the
white school library
I memorized James Weldon Johnson Paul
Laurence Dunbar Countee Cullen and
Langston Hughes I memorized Shakespeare
whole plays fifty sonnets
I memorized Edgar Allen Poe all the
poetry never having heard it
I memorized it I had Longfellow I had
Gita Maupassant
I had balsa Rudyard Kipling I mean it
was the Catholic kind of reading and
Catholic kind of story when I decided to
speak
I had a lot to say and many ways in
which to say what I had to say I listen
to the black minister and listen to the
melody of the preachers and I could tell
when they would start up from that kind
of thing when we didn't know they mean
to take our soul straight to heaven or
whether they meant to - just straight to
hell I understood it so out of this
either which was a dire kind of evil
because rape on the body of a young
person more often than not introduces
cynicism and there is nothing quite so
tragic as a young senic because it means
the person is going from knowing nothing
to believing nothing in my case I was
saved in that mutinous sea and the sort
of day I was saved and I was able to
draw from human thought human
disappointments and triumph enough to
triumph myself I see you as a brave
heart woman how do you see yourself dr.
Angelou a working woman every side yes
they always in the process I never take
your shoes off that's it I'm working all
the time I laugh as much as possible
yeah I just don't trust people who don't
die act as if I'm serious negative
they've got some kind of airplane gluon
stuck with fourth that fits the bed for
it I think I don't know if you're
serious about your blurring as it
becomes for hey that's for being serious
hmm I think if you're serious you try to
make a change if you don't like a
situation you try to change it do
whatever you can to change it and if
everything you do salt flat and
can't change it then change the way you
think about it move to another position
to look at it in doing so you may find a
new way to change
people will very often try to respond to
you on the level on which you address
them so if you say aren't you wonderful
aren't you then did my goodness you're
beautiful oh you're so bright people
will try even if they're not they really
will try to lift themselves after that
on the other hand if you say you know
you're a dog
you really also know you'll never be
anybody in fact you are nobody now and
you never have been sooner or later that
person will address will respond on the
level on which he or she is address we
will say figuratively or literally let
me show you where dog is let me show you
where low really is I will show you that
years ago I did a movie called quited
custard and there was a young man the
first day who first spoke I couldn't
believe it I walked around behind him
try to ignore him but the second day he
and another young man black man ran to
each other and they were about to fight
and hundreds of of extra started to run
away but one black man walked up to the
two young men and I was that and that's
just one bothered by his shoulder so let
me speak to you it's a rib please would
you do would do I said let me speak to
you honey you know I'll tell you
something you know you're as in no limit
obviously and I he finally calmed down
and I said do you know how much you need
it do you know what you mean to us do
you know that hundreds of years of
struggle have been for you you please
baby take a minute
don't lose your life on his own I put my
arm around him he started to weep tears
came down that was too fast sure cool
hmm he I took him I walk him down into a
little gully and kept his back to the
people so they wouldn't see him and I
used my hands to dry his cheek and I'd
kept talking to him Wheatley Wheatley
for the next week while I was on that
film whenever I walked by he
this end so I told it the good morning
miss answer dears try to introduce
courtesy into your speech to each other
you have no idea what it will do for
your brother or sister to whom you see
and you surely have no idea what it will
do for you it will lift you up and
Martin change request I'd rejoined the
seventy to me to talk because I had left
him to go to Mountain well there really
several movements like the cold I could
miss the National MS in the stage that
are so separated Mountain even made
Martin look like it at time until the
understood over that the minute right
and but that's a wonderful thing about
the icon you continue to grow and you
develop courage the most important of
all the virtues because without courage
you can't practice any other virtue
consistently if you've seen they know
the truth and had enough courage to
change your way of thinking to say hey
everybody you know what I said last week
I don't believe that anymore a little
child just freaked me out but I never by
my life there's nothing I don't love
about my life it's a struggle but that's
life that's why they call it life when I
see cruelty that's that's unfair come
listen
that's nasty good day to anyone just
rude and stupid but I don't see a lot of
that and if I do I try to do something
about it rather than I don't you sit in
the dark and curse the dark I try to
light a match you may write me down in
history with your bitter twisted line
you may tried me in the very dirt but
still like dust al
does my fashion and subsections
why are you be said the gloom just
because I walked as if I have oil wells
pumping in my living room just like
moons and like Suns with the certainty
of tides just like hope springing high
still like that did you want to see me
broken bowed head and lowered eyes
shoulders falling down like teardrops we
can buy my soulful crying does my
sassiness upset you don't take it to
heart just because I laugh as if I have
gold mines digging in my own backyard
you can shoot me with your words you can
cut me with your lives you can kill me
with your hatefulness but just like life
I learn does my sexiness offend you Oh
does it come as a surprise that I dance
as if I have diamonds at the meeting of
my thighs
out of the huts of history's shame I
ride up from a past rooted in pain I
ride a black ocean leaping and wide
Welling and swelling and bearing in the
time leaving behind nights of terror and
fear I rise into a daybreak miraculously
clear I rise bringing the gifts that my
ancestors gave I am the hope and the
dream of the slave and so bad thank you
guys so much for watching I'd love to
know what did you think of this video
what was the most inspiring moment from
this video that left its mark on you and
why leave in comments below I'm super
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to Lauren Lauren thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and making that
review on your YouTube channel about it
I really really really appreciate it and
I hope that you enjoyed the read this
week I read your one word by Evan
Carmichael and I've been a fan of eben
Carmichael's channel here on YouTube for
awhile he inspires entrepreneurs to go
out and just do their best so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon